and through this Summit we have advanced
the priorities of the British people
with two big aims Economic Security and
National Security
first Economic Security
on this trip we've secured almost 18
billion pounds of new investments into
the UK from Japanese businesses
that's a huge vote of confidence in the
United Kingdom creating hundreds of new
jobs with significantly more to come as
projects get underway
all helping to grow our economy one of
my five priorities for the UK
and alongside our unprecedented new
defense and security partnership it's
clear that the UK Japan relationship has
never been closer as we work together
with G7 allies to support a free and
open indo-pacific
the G7 also demonstrated Unity of
purpose on China
China poses the biggest challenge of our
age to Global Security and prosperity
they are increasingly authoritarian at
home and assertive abroad
and as the G7 have showed the UK's
response is completely aligned with our
allies
this is all about de-risking not
decoupling
and with the G7 we are taking steps to
prevent China from using economic
coercion to interfere in The Sovereign
Affairs of others
a new theme of this Summit was also AI
AI can bring huge benefits for our
economy society and public services
but of course it needs to be developed
safely securely and fairly
and that will require International
cooperation something that the UK is in
a natural position to lead
our second aim for this Summit was
National Security
all leaders at this Summit are grappling
with the issue of illegal migration
and my policy is this it is the British
government who will determine who comes
to Britain we must stop the boats and
break the business model of the criminal
gangs
this is a global issue and it will
increasingly be a focus of our
International engagement
just last week at the Council of Europe
we agreed to strengthen cooperation with
the eu's Border Force at this Summit we
secured the g7s agreement to deepen our
work together
and we expect this to be an important
focus of the G7 next year under Italy's
leadership
and there is no more pressing issue
facing the G7 and the world
the new crane
I want to pay tribute to my friend
Vladimir it was a privilege to welcome
him to Checkers earlier this week
and I believe his attendance at this G7
was a moment of historic significance
the image of the G7 and our partners
standing shoulder to shoulder with
president zielinski
sends a powerful message about the unity
and determination of the G7 allies
we will stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes because their security is
our security
the G7 strategy is clear
our military diplomatic and economic
tools are all part of the Ukrainian
counter-offensive
we're delivering more support on the
battlefield through Air Defense
Artillery tanks and long-range missiles
which the UK was the first country to
provide
we're supporting Ukraine to develop the
Air Force it needs for the future
with the UK trading Ukrainian Pilots
starting this summer
and we've made a real breakthrough at
this Summit thanks to President Biden's
support for an International Coalition
to provide F-16 Jets